Key to being a good dad.
Look, sometimes things work out just
the way you want. Sometimes they don't.
You got to hang in there.
90% of being a dad.
Just showing up.
I'm breaking the window.
Emergency assistance. This is.
Trina. Help! We. We locked our baby in
the car, and people are judging us.
I swear to God, I'm gonna break it.
Do not break the window. You'll get
glass on her. Sir, please.
Tell your wife to relax.
Everything is going to be okay.
That's a man.
Really? Don't worry.
Lily. Lily, Daddy's coming for you.
Sir, we just sent the signal.
The door should be unlocked.
Check the door. Check the door.
Check the door. It's not unlocked.
Oh. Oh, okay.
That is amazing.
How did they do that?
I don't know. It's just. We got it.
Thank you. Did that come from space.
Think fast.
Oh, wow.
Buddy, I'm sorry.
I told you I got to change the light
bulbs and then help your mom with those
signatures.
Never mind, because it was a stupid idea
anyways.
I've always said that if my son thinks
of me as one of his idiot friends, then
I've succeeded as a dad.
If he wants to go the wrong way on the
escalator, I'm on board.
If he wants to go into a restaurant and
pretend we're Australian, then.
G'day, mate. Toss a few shrimp on the
Barbie for me and my Joey.
Yeah, right. Nicole Kidman.
Men at work.
Here we go. Take 12.
Hey, buddy. I'm home.
Hey, Dad. Think fast. Oh.
Huh. Now my arm is starting to hurt a
little. Really?
Cause my face feels great.
Hello. Hey, have you ever.
Manny's waiting for you outside.
What? Why not?
Hold that thought.
His son is sitting on a curb waiting to
go to Disneyland, and Superman can't
drag himself away from a craps table.
And I'm the jerk.
Say, Listen. I.
Sorry, but I got some bad news.
What? Your dad couldn't make it.
Why not?
The plane was full, and this old lady
needed to get home, so he gave up his
seat.
You're making that up, aren't you?
No. He just didn't want to come.
Are you.
Kidding me? He was very upset.
He was dying to see you.
In fact, look what he sent.
A limo. Yeah.
He wanted me and your mom to take you
to Disneyland.
I told you he was an awesome dad.
Yeah, he's a prince.
Do I coddle her more than any other
loving parent?
And he.
It's possible.
And for Lily's sake, I should probably
work on that.
Give him your.
Credit card, Bill.
Also, this restaurant is pretty far
away, so we might be out late.
Well, sweetheart, you are only young
once.
Might even make sense to just stay in a
hotel.
Okay. Put it on the plastic.
Great.
Ha, ha.
Okay. See you tomorrow.
Bye Bye.
Uh, it's my ex wife, not the good one.
What do you.
Want? Nice game of chicken, Claire.
She's gone.
She's coming back. I am almost positive.
Almost.
Why do I listen to you? Why?
You were wrong about the iPod being a
failure. You were wrong about tomato
being a vegetable. I don't even want to
talk about your favorite planet, Pluto.
And unless she was lying to the good
ladies of The View, it's to me, not me.
You were going to let me go with him.
Isn't that what you wanted? Honey,
what's the
matter with you? You've been acting so
weird ever since I left college.
For the record, you didn't leave
college. You were asked to leave.
Oh, you guys never let me forget.
Especially Dad.
Honey, your father.
Oh, you don't
have to tell me what he thinks, okay?
I'm a huge disappointment to him.
I see it on his face every day.
He acts as if he doesn't even want me
around.
Give me the ticket for the car. Phil,
I'm going after her. This little
chicken game may work for your dad, but
it doesn't work for me. That's my
little girl. I need her to know that no
guy on earth is good enough for her,
let alone some slimy, middle aged jean
salesman.
What is this? Just enjoy it.
Your teacher tells me you don't want to
dance. Is that true?
But you were so good back at the house
when you were practicing.
I want to go home.
To my house.
To your house, huh?
Are you sad your dads aren't here?
Yeah.
And I know they're sad to miss this, but
they're getting you that baby brother.
That's good, right?
You know, honey.
Your dads are going to love you just as
much when you get this. Brother.
Trust me. I first had your Aunt Claire,
and then your dad came along.
And I loved them just the same.
No matter what he tells you, believe
me. Close enough.
So what do you say? You're going to go
out there and dance for everybody?
No.
Honey, there must be something I can do
to get you out there.
Come dance with me, Grandpa.
No, honey, that's not going to happen.
How about I give you 50 bucks?
Come on.
Daddy. It's time for our wedding.
What's happening now?
Lily and I are getting married.
What's happening? When she proposed.
I thought it was a little weird, but
then I read. It's a phase that some
girls go through, so.
Oh, no.
Well, I just think it's the cutest thing
ever. Here, Dad.
I made you this ring.
Oh, cute, cute, cute, cute, cute, cute,
cute.
Do you have a ring for me?
Well, Lily, it wouldn't be a wedding
without a ring.
Yeah.
Hey, loving this.
Daddy move.
Okay, I guess I'll just go sit on the
groom's side.
Oh, come on, Cam.
It's fun.
No, it's fun.
It's super fun.
He finally got married.
Hooray! Ouh.
Are you okay, sweetie?
What do you think?
Wait a minute. You won.
Congratulations.
Please don't be happy for me.
I can't take it.
I was such a jerk to you.
No, honey, I get it.
I know I can be embarrassing.
I just get nervous around smart people
sometimes. Even you.
The first time I ever said quiet.
Quiet was when you were six years old.
And you just told me about how plants
make carbon dioxide.
This may surprise you, but sometimes I
wish I was more like you.
The way you're always able to enjoy
life.
Believe it or not, I felt the same way
about my dad. I'm a I'm a pessimist
compared to him. And his dad actually
suffered from a smile induced hernia.
It's prank week and I spent the whole
time in the library.
Sometimes I feel like I just went
through the four best years of my life.
Only I forgot to make them the four
best years of my life.
Well, college isn't over, and I just may
be able to help you make up for a
little lost time.
Hot wing trivia is about to start.
I have you guys registered as the
Dunphys. How did you.
You knew I was coming.
Let's not forget where you learned about
that tracking app.
And there's one tiny change we had,
actually, the Mac Dunphys.
Only my dad would think that a trivia
game, the Triangle Shirtwaist fire,
where you balance hats on your head,
drink beer as a reward.
Kareem Abdul Jabbar and.
Eat hot wings as a punishment.
Millard Fillmore needed that one last
twist of a Scottish accent.
Dopey.
Sneezy and grumpy.
No, no, no, no, no, no. Take those
things off, please.
We need to talk about whatever's going
on with you right now.
I'm fine.
No, you're not fine.
You're sullen and aloof, and.
And you embarrassed us in front of
Kimmy Love. And I can't say it again.
I can't. Okay.
We gave you every tween girl's dream
day, and you could barely crack a
smile.
It's not my dream day.
It's yours.
I'm not the same kind of tween girl you
guys are.
But we love all the same things.
I've changed.
I don't like Beyonce.
Take that back.
Or Britney or Gaga.
I only fake it because you guys like
that stuff.
I'm different.
Well, honey, is it.
Is that why you've been feeling so
down? Because you feel different than
us? I don't
know. I guess I feel different than a
lot of people. Well.
Sweetie, that is one thing your dad and
I can relate to.
I guess that's the great thing about
having two gay dads.
We know what it feels like to be an
outsider. Okay, But here's what
happens. You start finding people who
don't quite fit in and you start not
fitting in together.
We never want you to feel like you have
to be someone else for us.
Never. What is this music you're always
listening to?
Come on, let us in. Yeah.
Okay. I like this.
Let's put it on, huh?
Here we go.
We've got business.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. I like it.
She's going to kill us some.
How often do your fathers get married so
far? One, two.
Why am I still seeing you?
Take your seat that we're about to
start.
Actually, I thought you and I would take
a little walk.